protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
slide coming up
watch out new timepieces from the
original crowdfunded company we take a
look at the flat-pack go-kart made of
wood and we try it a few games for your
phone or tablet
welcome to swipe this week from
Barcelona at the Mobile World Congress
simply the biggest gathering of the
mobile tech industry anywhere in the
world at this year's show we've seen
plenty of smart handsets smart tablets
smart applications by the Dozen but a
particular focus was new smart watches
it's a beautiful color screen but ePaper
means that it doesn't use that much
battery power pebble is a kickstarter
phenomenon at the end of February they
asked for half a million dollars
investment they passed the million
dollar mark in just 40 minutes so this
is the main watch base you can press the
down button to see what's coming up next
a meeting the weather calendar and you
can see what just happened if pebble
watches use a functional square face the
Huawei have done a more circular route
their watch is designed as a piece of
jewelry even bearing a classic face
albeit an electronic one the brief was
very much to design a traditional and
classic watch you know fashion the
timepiece and this has a lot of
traditional watch elements for example
there's the the top ring and the crown
and also the case back in it but it's
imaging to know the case bag is made out
of metal and a lot of other smile
watches there the actual case back is
plastic so this gives it's very much a
very much a luxury feel
and within a matter of hours after
you've watched this program we may learn
more about Apple's timely offering first
introduced last September I don't think
we feel threatened I think we feel it's
incredibly exciting to be honest we've
been working on this for seven years and
now the world's attention is focusing on
smartwatches I think this is our time to
shine and to really tell the story about
what we've been working on for so many
years and talking of Apple rivalry the
iPhone six came under attack at MWC from
their South Korean rivals Samsung the
galaxy s6 is not so much a rival as a
mirror model aping Apple's dimensions
and functionality in many ways but
superior in others they say we've had a
look at some of the things that are
really key for people in this smartphone
usage it simmer sure market now people
know what they like people know what
they want we've really tried to answer
those questions from ground zero
on this one well this is HTC's flagship
phone for 2015 the m9 very similar form
factor different materials used and a
softer metal edge they say to make the
phone easier to hold the user interface
has changed it's clever now when you
fire up the phone at home it offers you
the home apps on the home screen in the
car
motoring apps and when you get to the
office it offers you your work apps also
in Barcelona Ford were suggesting we get
out of their cars and onto an e-bike and
they have an app for that
it has haptic features on the handlebars
so that as a car approaches you it will
buzz you can plan your trip using an
application on a mobile phone and then
as you're riding the bike it will tell
you when you need to turn it'll turn the
signals on for you it has auto grade
headlamps and and brakes staying on two
wheels here's a demo a state-of-the-art
sensor technology taking sports to new
heights so what we want to do is do 3d
motion tracking cracks
sports so where GPS would only give you
speed and any vertical was five meters
at best with accuracy we needed to see
it to three millimeter precision you
know exactly how high we jump so we
create a device that has dual
constellation GPS was also packed with a
bunch of inertial sensors accelerometers
gyroscopes magnetometer barometric
pressure sensor what you're getting in
essence is like HD GPS is what we like
to call it back on four wheels more
ubiquitous connectivity on show at the
Vodafone stand and of course in the car
space in the mobile space telematics is
the real theme of the show this year
this unit is being put into every
Porsche at the factory level from the
get-go and then the accompanying app
will means you can check on the car
change the car modify its behavior
including putting the heater on so
imagine this it's a cold morning you
want the car to be nice and warm
you can fire up the heater while you
have your breakfast later we'll review
the latest mobile games but first here's
a roundup of some of the stories you may
have missed over the last few days
Ubisoft's working on a tablet video game
designed to help people with a lazy eye
players put on red and blue glasses a
bit like the ones used for old 3d movies
and the game's graphics are shown in the
same colors this forces them to use
their dominant and weaker eyes together
which will hopefully improve vision the
government's backing plans to build a
spaceport in the UK by 2018 if it
happens it'll become the first spaceport
in Europe from off a commercial space
travel and ultra-fast international
flights five potential summits are in
the running campbelltown Glasgow and
Stornoway in Scotland nuki in England
and flam better in Wales you might have
put together a flat-pack wardrobe before
but how about a flat packed go-kart
while the team in the US has created a
prototype made from plywood it's not
quite as quick as putting together
furniture though they'll have to set
aside a whole day to finish the job
they're looking for around 23,000 pounds
of funding through Kickstarter
and from one Kickstarter project to
another a gadget that claims it can turn
into any instrument you want it to be
hit its funding goal of 49 thousand
pounds this week in just over five hours
the Artie Phan uses a touch-sensitive
digital fretboard to create the notes
and connects to smartphones tablets or
computers a lot of time here at Mobile
World Congress is spent looking at new
handsets and finding out what they can
or cannot do and for gamers one of the
most important things that new phone
might have is the ability to play bigger
and better games so here's a rundown of
some of the newest titles agent Alice is
a hidden-object game for iPhone and iPad
and it kind of says what it does on the
tin really you get presented with the
scene and a list of things that you have
to find in it and if you find these
things very quickly you rack up those
pointy it's got beautiful artwork it's
this 1960s vibe it's just quite a nice
easygoing puzzle games free so it's
always worth a go but if you're just
looking for something that's nice and
relaxing to maybe play on a tube journey
or something it's a good game
Altos adventure is an endless runner
game so it's just you know keep going
until you die basically and you play as
a llama shepherd Alto and do you have a
snowboard and you're it's snowboarding
down a hill and you're you're basically
corralling all of your lost llamas but
while you're doing it it's you grind on
things like bunting grind on tables do
tricks and backflips and it's one of
those games where everything just works
works right and looks great and the
music's lovely kind of a zen-like
experience and it's a really nice game
to just sort of have a crack out and see
have a go for a couple of minutes and
put to one side or maybe come back to
and try and beat your school
dark echo is quite an unusual game in
that it's a horror game but you can't
see what you're afraid of
so it's basically like coining in on the
are you afraid of the dark
the screen is pitch-black and by moving
your character your footsteps create
these kind of so not these lines that
come out from you and they kind of
crudely map out the area or in it's one
that's best played when you're sort of
in maybe even in the dark yourself but
wearing headphones and just totally
immersed in it and it's it's a really
great find for fans of games like
wipeout and f-zero we've now got this
iPad equivalent which is a tea drive and
there's been a few but this one is
really great it really looks the part
so you're basically controlling this
hovercraft around a really futuristic
looking racetrack and honestly it's one
of the best looking games out there on
the iPad that moment and you can either
use tilt controls to control your
hovercraft or you can use touchpad
controls it's pretty difficult game it's
not very forgiving but you do kind of
get in get the hang of you know using
your speed boost properly trying to race
against other people it's a lot of fun
your car can also come with special kind
of power-ups you can either jump or you
can have this turbo boost that's really
useful because if like me you always
find yourself at the far end of the park
is it pass people it's big it's a quite
a nice just sort of gratifying
experience a G Drive make all these well
that's it for this week remember you can
keep up-to-date with all the breaking
tech stories throughout the week on sky
news for iPad
our smartphone applications and at Sky
News comm from Martin Stanford in
Barcelona goodbye
protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News